[Music]
teaching is one of the most important
and gratifying endeavors that we can
have
and medical teaching has the extra power
of not only helping learners but
ultimately helping those whom they treat
clinical teaching is challenging it's a
complex combination
of content context and process
and after 35 years of developing
teaching improvement curricula
and training medical teachers from
around the world we can assure you that
all teachers at some point struggle with
issues like learner engagement
setting goals and giving feedback we
designed this course to help you
increase the effectiveness of your
teaching
regardless of your setting content area
and learner characteristics
when you finish the course you will have
a set of practical tools to help you
improve your teaching effectiveness
in any context by enrolling in this
course
you will join a cohort of over 30 000
other medical teachers from over 20
countries
who have attended our in-person teacher
training programs
you will learn an educational framework
for analyzing and improving your
teaching
the course adopts a non-prescriptive
philosophy offering teachers a menu of
approaches to implement
in their teaching practice we've invited
four physician faculty who have received
the facilitator training at our center
to join us in the presentation of this
course
each of them is highly experienced in
making presentations for medical
teachers locally
nationally and internationally
we both sincerely hope that this course
on mastering medical teaching will be as
useful for you
as it has been for so many others around
the world
you